don't even worry about getting the
education just do what you need to do on
the field so many kids get it sugar card
because everybody is telling them
they're the best player in the world
[Music]
you send young kids on the roller
coaster you recruit them you bring them
in swimming sign you switch up kind of
you're here for a job but then you don't
pay me
what's its take for a university if a
player makes money off their own
likeness the coaches are making millions
coaching players whose families live
below the poverty line I thought I would
be playing professionally right now I
never would expected to be here the
propellant billion-dollar industry
getting sweatsuit for
[Applause]
you